OK, let's get started.
Settle down. A couple of
announcements to make: it is with
great sadness that I announced that
there will be no lecture on Monday.
Yeah, I know. With all the Kleenex
consumed, Kimberly-Clark went up two
points on the New York Stock
Exchange yesterday,
which is incredible.
And, in view of the timing of where
we are on the lectures versus the
homework, and no opportunity to
interact with the recitation
instructors on Monday,
what we are doing just this one time,
we're going to slide the weekly quiz
over to Thursday.
And, that gives more time for people
to contact their recitation
instructors. Well,
let's get on with the lesson.
Perhaps some of you haven't figured
out that the lecture has started.
And I still hear talking. And I
will invite people to leave if they
insist on talking.
So, last day, we talked about
secondary bonding,
and we looked at various forms of
secondary bonding.
Here's the cartoons,
dipole-dipole interactions,
dipole induced, dipole in solutions,
a little bit of a diversion, induced
dipole, induced dipole,
which was the London dispersion
forces, or van der Waals bonds,
and also hydrogen bonding.
And, all of these helped us answer
the question, what's the state of
aggregation? The reason we want to
know the state of aggregation is
that this is solid-state chemistry.
And we want to know when something
is a solid. So,
this helps us get to that conclusion.
And, then we came to the point
where we realized that three
quarters of the periodic table
wasn't covered by either ionic
bonding, covalent bonding,
or van der Waals bonding as a
primary form of bonding.
So, we had to come up with something
else. And that something else was
metallic bonding.
We saw Paul Drude's early attempt
in 1900 to model metals as a gas of
free electrons moving about ion
cores, where the ion core,
in fact, is a mix of the nucleus
plus all the inner shell electrons.
And, we recognize that that didn't
take us very far.
So, what we want to do is continue
the discussion.
And today we're going to look at
the next installments,
which took place about 30 years
later as part of the
quantum revolution,
And, there's really two benchmarks
here. The first one is by Felix
Bloch, and this came out in 1928.
This was his Ph.D. thesis. What he
did for his Ph.
. thesis, which was done under the
supervision of Heisenberg at Leipzig,
took on an interesting problem.
So far, you've seen quantum theory
applied to gases,
right? Bohr talked about atomic
hydrogen.
And, you know the complexities of
condensed matter.
Bloch's Ph.D. thesis: quantum
theory of solids.
Let's take quantum theory and apply
it to solids, not bad for an opener.
Quantum theory of solids was his Ph.
. thesis.
And, here's what he did.
You can follow. I'm not going to
give you the derivations,
but it's quite simple. First,
he recognizes that atoms in a metal
are arranged in periodic positions.
There is an array. It's not just
thrown together in some jumble.
So, atoms in solid set in regular
patterns. We're going to learn
these patterns next week,
arrays, and such solids where the
atoms are found in regular patterns
are called crystals.
So, he took that as one benchmark.
The second thing: he says that,
remember, Drude says that the
valence electrons are free to move
around. And, he says,
well, if these valence electrons are
free to move around,
what would they be subjected to?
They would be subjected to a
potential. This is how we derived
the energy levels in even a single
hydrogen atom.
We've got the positive charge of
the core; we've got the negative
charge of the electron.
So, now I've got an electron,
and it sees the net positive charge
of the atomic core.
But, it sees an array.
It sees periodic variation in
potential. So,
that's the second thing he says:
periodic potential acts on
the valence electrons.
And then, he invokes wave mechanics.
Remember, Schršdinger's equation
was only enunciated a couple years
earlier, in 1926.
There's a Ph.D. student who hears
about the Schršdinger equation as
applied to a gaseous atom.
And, he's applying it to condensed
matter. And so,
he solves the Schršdinger equation
with these constraints.
And, what does he get?
He gets a set of solutions.
He gets a family of solutions.
And, these give rise to a set of
wavelengths of the electron that
could move quickly through the
crystal, they could propagate.
In other words, by invoking the
wavelength properties of the
electron, he can rationalize how
these valence electrons can move
through barriers that classical
physics would impose.
And so, pretty soon,
out falls electronic conductivity.
So, this is pretty good for an
opening volley,
not bad for a Ph.
. And, he eventually took on some
faculty positions,
and then in the 1930's,
when the Nazis came to power,
Bloch, as did many of the scientists
from Europe left and came to the
United States. And, he
settled at Stanford.
And, eventually he won a Nobel Prize,
but not for this work.
This was OK, but he got a Nobel
Prize in 1952 for work he started in
1945 that had to do with magnetic
moments in the nucleus.
So, he had more than one good idea.
So, that's the first thing we need
to take into account
in the band theory.
The second was a pair of gentlemen:
Walter Heitler,
and same man as from last lecture,
Fritz London. This was before he
came up with the dispersion idea.
Dispersion bonding was 1930. But
he and Heitler decided to go in 1927
to Zurich, and spend a year
postdocing with Schršdinger.
Little did they know that
Schršdinger had negotiated
a position at Berlin.
And, they no sooner arrived than
Schršdinger left.
But anyways, that's what brought
them to Zurich.
And they decided,
let's take this idea of linear
combination of atomic orbitals,
and instead of asking rinky-dink
questions like,
is lithium-2 stable?
Is helium-2 stable? And looking at
bonding versus anti-bonding,
he said let's ask, if we take
Avogadro's number of wave functions
and blend them in something like
copper, can we make sense
of what's going on?
So, this is what their contribution
was. It was linear combination of
atomic orbitals into molecular
orbitals for large ensembles.
And so, here's how that goes.
Let's take a look at the cartoon.
You recall last day we looked at
something like if we wanted to ask
whether A blends with another A to
make A2, we can start at some level.
I'm going to just look at the
valence shell, OK?
So, I look at the valence orbitals.
This is atomic orbitals. And, when
these two come close together,
when these two atoms become close
enough that they're operating as one
system in order not to violate the
Pauli exclusion principle these
energies have to shift a little bit.
Otherwise we run the risk of having
more than one electron with the same
set of quantum numbers.
So, these will rearrange themselves
into what we call anti-bonding and
bonding orbitals,
where anti-bonding are at slightly
higher energy than the parent atomic
orbital, and bonding are at slightly
lower energy than the
parent orbital.
So, this is A2.
Now, suppose I do this one more
time. Suppose I take A plus A2,
and I want to make A3. What would
happen if I took A plus A2?
Well, again, not to violate the
Pauli exclusion principle,
this initial, whatever this orbital
is, let's call it ns, I don't know.
Maybe it's 3s,
whatever, it's going to have to
allow for that number of states.
And, I think you can see by analogy,
this is what Heitler and London did.
They kept going until they got An,
where n is large.
How large? Oh, a crystal about the
size of your thumb,
on the order of a cubic centimeter,
in other words, a block of metal.
So, when n is large,
what happens? So, this thing keeps
going. There's a little bit of a
broadening. But,
this is what happens.
We have many, many levels here
starting at the highest anti-bonding
down to the lowest bonding.
But now, the space, the energy
difference between successive levels
is getting vanishingly small.
And in fact, you can think about it.
How many atoms would there be in a
cubic centimeter of copper?
Well, let's think about that.
If I've got a cubic centimeter of
copper, I can look on the periodic
table. If you look on the periodic
table, the molar volume,
they call it atomic volume,
but the molar volume of copper is 7.
1 cubic centimeters. So, there's
Avogadro's number there, right?
Who is buried in Grant's tomb?
Grant. How many atoms in a molar
volume? One mole.
So, this contains N Avogadro atoms.
So, divide in. So, N Avogadro
atoms, you can divide through and
pretty soon, you figure out how many
states there are.
If I go 1 cubic centimeter,
it's roughly 10 to the 23 atoms per
centimeter cubed.
So, that means I'm going to have 10
to the 23 states here.
And, what's this energy difference?
It's on the order of some tens of
electron volts.
So, suppose I put in here.
I'll even give you 1,000 electron
volts because I've got a lot of
protons in the nucleus.
Suppose this is on the order of ten
to the third eV,
but it's divided by 10 to the 23rd
contributors. So,
what's the delta in here?
It's about ten to the minus 20
electron volts,
which is about ten to the minus 40
joules.
I mean, this is less energy than the
movement of the eyeball of the
mosquito. There's nothing here.
There's nothing. So, from a
distance, if I get up really close,
this is still Aufbau principle. So,
the electrons come in two by two
just as Noah's ark,
from the bottom up to the top.
These are all distinct quantum
states. But from a distance,
they are so close together that this
appears to be a band, almost
a continuum, a band.
So, the band is a set of very
closely spaced orbitals.
And now, you see how to populate,
and for something like copper, we
know copper is argon 3d104s1.
So, copper is two by two coming in.
And, they'll fill up to the halfway
point of the band because I can put
two per orbital.
But, I only have one per copper.
So, if I blow this up, what do I
have? I've got this band that's
half filled. This is the S band,
and it's half filled. And then, the
next level is a vanishingly small
energy difference.
And so, if then I apply a potential,
let's say I make this side of the
crystal negative,
and I make the side of the crystal
positive, it takes a tiny bit of
energy to pull an electron out of
the topmost orbital,
put it up here, and now it's free to
move about the crystal.
So, this accounts for the high
degree of metallic nature of
materials because the energy levels
are so close together.
In the past, we saw for classical
gas phase atoms,
it took a substantial amount of
energy to move something out of its
ground state. In this case,
to move out of ground state takes a
trivial amount of energy.
And, I think I've got some cartoons
that indicate this.
This goes back to Drude with his
cation. Some books will actually
call the atomic core as cations.
But, they're being sloppy with the
terminology because it's the ionic
core consisting of the protons of
the nucleus plus the inner shell
electrons. But,
in electrical engineering,
they'll refer to this as cations and
then the sea of valence electrons.
So, here's a cartoon showing what's
happening as you progressively add
larger and larger numbers,
and not to violate the Pauli
exclusion principle.
You have to keep shifting the
energies. And,
since you only have one electron
here, as you move out in this case,
sodium, you will find you are
filling two by two,
and all of the bonding orbitals are
filled with a tiny energy difference.
And, this is out of the reading.
This is the same idea, only it's
done in the case of lithium.
And lastly, this is the idea I was
just trying to get across that
here's the metal sitting at rest.
And now, there is an electrical
potential put across it,
which wants to move electrons,
and even with a modest potential,
that's enough to disrupt the bonding
here in the uppermost levels,
and cause electrons to rise, and
then move along the anti-bonding
orbitals quite freely.
So, that gives us a sense of what's
going on in the conductivity of
something like copper or sodium.
But, now let's think about
something like magnesium.
Magnesium is a metal.
But let's think about what's going
on with magnesium.
Magnesium has 3s, but it has 3s2 in
the case of magnesium.
Magnesium is 3s2. So,
if we start filling magnesium s-band,
we're going to fill two by two all
the way up to the top.
If this is s, and the p's are up
here, what happens when the p's
split into the bands?
That's the real issue.
And, mercifully, what happens in
the case of magnesium is
this is the s-band.
But for magnesium,
the p-band, the bottom of the p-band
lies below the top of the s-band.
So, in the case of magnesium, this
is now the p-band.
And, the p-band energy levels are
available so that when we fill the
top of the s-band,
we can continue to move into a range
of energy that allows for motion.
So, we are able to account for both
unpaired electron atoms,
and paired electron atoms by this
overlap of energies.
And, I think there's a cartoon in
your reading that indicates that.
Yeah, this shows what happens with
the energy levels as a function of
distance. And,
you can see that the p-band is now
dropping below the top of the s-band,
and so it allows for continuous
filling into more states.
And so, this now accounts for not
only such things as electrical
conductivity, but reflectivity.
Metals have luster because the
photons of visible light have the
capacity to excite electrons,
which immediately cascade down and
reflect back. So,
band theory became widespread in
popularity. In the 20s,
it was known only about a few
physicists. In the 30s,
the scientific community knew it.
In the 40s, it infected the popular
culture. If you talk to your
grandparents, they'll refer to the
40s as the big band era
because of this.
Maybe you thought that the reason
the big band era was named the big
band era was due to people like
Glenn Miller, Benny Goodman,
Tommy Dorsey. No, it was due to
Felix Bloch, Walter Heitler,
and Fritz London. So, I don't want
you thinking about those bandleaders
anymore. This is the band.
This is the big band right here.
All right, so now let's go on to
something a little more interesting.
One of the other shortcomings that
was not addressed by Drude was the
ability to distinguish between
metals and insulators.
So, let's see if this theory can do
that. So, let's go to something
like diamond. So,
if we start with diamond,
here's carbon as a single gas
molecule, and we start
off with 2s and 2p.
And we know that this,
then, hybridizes to maximize bonding
capability. So this is now sp3.
And, I'm going to put a two here
for reasons that will become
apparent in a minute.
So, this is now carbon in the
diamond configuration has a single
gas molecule. Now,
I know this is sort of the sound of
one hand clapping,
but this is the lone carbon that is
waiting to form diamond.
And I'm going to skip over the
di-diamond and the tri-diamond.
That's just go to diamond crystal.
So, what will happen is these
levels will divide,
and in accordance with Pauli
exclusion principle,
will start up here with the
anti-bonding, and we'll start out
here with the bonding.
And, what happens in the case of
diamond is that when the population
of anti-bonding descends,
there is energy gap between the
bottom of the anti-bonding orbitals
and the top of the bonding orbitals.
So, we have two bands here.
Before, we simply had a single band.
This would have given us an s band.
This would all come from sp3
forming sigma bonds.
But, in this case, there is a big
divide here. So,
this is the energy gap.
Or, some people call it the band
gap. And, the energy here is given
a symbol, E sub g,
the band gap energy.
And, in the case of diamond,
the band gap energy is 5.4 electron
volts in diamond.
So, what happens now?
Now, let's fill this,
one, two, three, four, and if we
count this properly,
see, we've got single occupancy.
We fill to the top of the valence
band. This is known as valence band
because these were bonding orbitals.
We fill to the top of the valence
band, and now if we want to apply an
electrical potential to cause these
electrons to come out of the bonds
and move up and down the crystal,
we've got to come up with 5.4 eV,
which is a substantial amount of
energy, and doesn't happen.
So, as a result, this is an
insulator. So,
we now have the capacity to
distinguish between metals
and insulators.
Insulators have high band gaps,
typically on the order of about
three electron volts.
Metals have no band gap,
continuous availability of these
closely spaced orbitals.
And, while we're in the
neighborhood, this upper band that
consists of all of the anti-bonding
orbitals is called the conduction
band because this doesn't involve
bonding. So, if an electron is in
this upper band,
it's free to move,
and under the influence of
electrical potential, it will do so.
So, we have valence band,
conduction band, band gap.
Now, let's look at one other one.
Let's look at silicon. Let's look
at silicon. Silicon is in the same
family. It's group four,
sp3 hybridized, only in the case of
silicon, we're going to start with
3s atomic orbital.
And, the 3p atomic orbitals,
which hybridize to give us sp3,
but now n equals three. And, if we
bring a large number of silicons
together, we will form,
as in the case of diamond,
a valence band and a conduction band.
The difference here is that - let's
think about the strength of these
bonds. The bonds are down here in
the valence band.
Electrons in pairs,
these are covalent bonds all the way
up to the top of the valence band.
This is n equals three in contrast
to n equals two.
So, what do we know about the
relative strength of a bond in n
equals three versus n equals two?
Is it going to be stronger or
weaker?
Expected to be weaker.
It's farther from the nucleus.
And, indeed, this is manifest by
the fact that the separation between
anti-bonding and bonding is not as
great because we know that when
something moves from atomic orbital
to molecular orbital,
this is the change in energy,
going from the atomic orbital to the
molecular orbital.
So, if I have a stronger bond,
doesn't it stand to reason that the
energy difference between an atomic
orbital and the molecular orbital
will be greater for a stronger bond/
This is weaker.
So, therefore, this separation
isn't as great as it is in diamond,
and indeed, the band gap in silicon
is on the order of 1.
electron volts. And,
1.1 electron volts is on a special
range. What else do we know that's
on the order of several
electron volts?
That's really critical here.
Critical here is visible light.
Visible light is on the order of
two to three electron volts.
So, what happens in this case with
respect to visible light?
If visible light shines on diamond,
it's transparent because the energy
gap is 5.4 electron volts.
If visible light shines on silicon,
it's absorbed because visible light
has greater than 1.1 eV.
And, this is an 800 millimeter
silicon crystal.
This has been cut and polished from
a giant single crystal salami,
cut, and this is down to one atom
fidelity. But,
you can see it appears black because
the visible light that reaches
it is absorbed.
And you say, well,
what's the reflectivity from?
Well, there is a thin oxide film,
and that's the topic of another
lecture. But,
the material itself is dark because
the energy level here is less than
anything that you'll find in visible
light. You know,
that got me thinking.
If a photon comes in like this,
a photon of visible light, what will
happen? Photon of visible light
will hit an electron sitting here,
and excite the electron, won't it?
But that electron is going to be the
same thing that happened in Ballmer
and Angstrom's gas tube.
This is a one shot deal.
The electron rises, but it's not
sustained. So,
what happens immediately thereafter?
The electron falls back down and
reemits. So, this is
photo-excitation.
And, if this energy,
if this E incident, if this is
greater than 1.
eV, suppose it's 1.
eV, things get more complicated.
We're not going to go into all the
quantum mechanics,
just suffice it to say,
that excess energy will go up into
the crystal and will be dissipated
as heat. And,
as far as 3.091 is concerned,
if the incident energy is greater
than the band gap energy.
Expect excitation, loss of excess
energy, and then this electron will
fall back down and give us an
emitted photon at exactly equal the
band gap energy, right?
This would be hc over lambda
directly band gap.
You know, there's something here
that's intriguing.
You've got this electron up here.
Wouldn't it be cool if you could
take the backside of the silicon,
and connect it to an external
circuit, and shine light on the
silicon, and then cause the photons
to excite electrons,
which could then power something?
That would be photovoltaics,
wouldn't it? That would be how a
solar cell works,
wouldn't it? If you wanted a sensor
that took visible light,
that strikes it, and then captures
that electron,
and then sends it to a detector,
and maybe if you made an array of
these, and so that light that comes
at different intensities on
different pixels sends currents at
different intensities,
that would be interesting too,
wouldn't it?
Can you see why the band gap,
being 1.1 eV versus visible light is
really important?
How about this? What if instead of
having light coming in,
what if I connected this to a power
supply, and I pumped the electrons
out of the valence band into the
conduction band from which they
would fall, and then emit photons?
So, I could make a light emitting
device by pumping things up and
having them fall down.
This is why this class of materials
is dominating the modern world.
Materials with a band gap around
the value of the energy in visible
light are called semiconductors,
for reasons you'll see shortly in
terms of their conductivity.
Their electrical conductivity is the
least appealing of their properties.
It's their ability to interact with
radiation that makes them so
exciting. And,
actually, you know,
we could actually do a test.
We could actually measure what
these band gaps are by tuning the
value of the incident radiation.
So, for example,
if we did this with long wave
radiation, keep moving,
moving, moving until we get to a
value of photon energy that causes
excitation, we could have a sensor
that detects when the incident
radiation is being absorbed.
And, we could plot that energy as
follows. We could have this as,
say, the lambda of the incident
energy, lambda the incident energy,
and this as the percent absorption.
This is the percent absorption by
the crystal. And,
this would go from zero to 100.
So, energy moves from right to left.
It goes inversely with lambda.
So, high wavelength is low energy.
So, at low energy, we expect
materials to be transparent.
At high energy,
they will absorb,
and at some critical value of energy,
absorption begins.
And this value here is called the
absorption edge.
So, out here at very,
very high wavelengths, or low
energies, the material appears
transparent because E incident is
less than E of the band gap.
And, at high energies,
the material appears opaque.
Its absorbing because here E
incident is greater than E of the
band gap. And,
this roundedness here is due to
defects. It's not a perfectly sharp
edge. And so,
what I did is I said,
OK, well let's do the calculation.
Soy compared silicon and diamond.
So, the band gaps in electron volts,
for silicon it's 1.
. For diamond it's 5.
. And then, all I did is just said,
well, band gap energy is now
converted to photon energy.
So, just do hc over lambda.
So, lambda of the absorption edge,
this is equal to, band gap is equal
to hc over lambda of
the absorption edge.
For silicon, it's way out in the
infrared. It's 1,
25, I'm going to use these ugly
units, nanometers,
and diamond is down at 229 nm.
And, where is visible light?
Visible light is,
round numbers, 400-700 nm.
So, you can see that this is out in
the IR. And, this is down in the UV.
So, we could make a plot here.
If this is 400 nm,
this is 700 nm. So,
this is visible light.
Then, this would be silicon out
here at 1,125 nm,
And diamond over here at 229
nanometers, and visible light right
in between. And I thought,
well, there's probably another
chemistry lesson here.
So, first of all, just to summarize,
we've seen here that the
metal has no band gap.
So, there's no gap between the top
of the bonding and the bottom of the
anti-bonding orbitals.
In an insulator, there's a huge
band gap, and in the semiconductor
there is a moderate band gap,
where moderate is defined literally
in reference to visible light.
Now, this was an interesting thing.
Here's your group 14, or group four
off the periodic table.
And, these are the values of band
gap energy. I've already showed you
that diamond is 5.
, and silicon is 1.
. And, again, now germanium is
going out to n equals four so that
sp3 hybridizes.
This is 4s2, 4p2 forms four sp3
hybrid orbitals,
0.72. Tin: it may surprise you.
Tin has two different
crystallographic forms.
They are called allotropes.
One of them is metallic,
and the other one is sp3 hybridized.
So, tin actually has a
semiconducting form.
It's a tiny, tiny band gap,
but it's nonzero. And then, lastly,
lead has got so many electrons, the
valence electrons are so weakly held
that there's no propensity for
covalency, and so it exists only in
metallic form.
But you can see the trends very
nicely scaling with the intensity of
the bonding as exemplified by the
pull on the nucleus on the
outer shell electrons.
OK, well, I talked about
photoexcitation.
There is another way to excite
electrons, and that's by thermal
excitation. Just the energy in the
environment could lead to promotion
of the electrons from the valence
band to the conduction band.
So, I'd like to look at that
process.
Let's look at thermal excitation.
So, again, I'm going to simplify
this. The upper anti-bonding
orbitals represented here as the
conduction band,
and the lower filled bonding
orbitals are represented as the
valence band. There is fine
structure in here.
These are electrons,
two by two, all the way up through
here, all right?
So, let's suppose we have enough
thermal energy so that E thermal is
greater than band gap energy.
If the thermal energy of the system
were greater than the band gap
energy, we would have the ability to
break these bonds and promote
electrons across the band gap.
So, what happens? Let's look at
that process. So,
I'm going to rip an electron out of
an orbital here,
rip an electron out of an orbital,
and send it up to the conduction
band.
So, one electron is now moved from
the valence band to the conduction
band leaving behind a half filled
orbital so it's pretty clear that we
now have a new carrier in the
conduction band.
So we have a negative carrier in
the conduction band.
But, what's interesting is what's
happening down here in
the valence band.
This broken bond,
this single electron in a bonding
orbital is like a hot potato.
Nobody wants this thing. It's
highly unstable.
And so, what will happen is if we
put this crystal between two
electrodes, and so let's say we
polarize the right electrode
negative, and the left electrode
positive, it doesn't surprise you
that the electron will be repelled
by the negative electrode and drawn
to the positive electrode.
It will move from right to left.
This broken bond, I'm drawing it
here as in energy space,
but you can imagine a lattice full
of silicons. This broken bond will
actually propagate.
And since the broken bond is a zero
in a land of minus one,
it has an apparent charge of plus.
And, this represents essentially a
vacancy in a bonding orbital,
and is termed a hole.
This is termed a hole.
It's designated lowercase h,
and it has charge plus one. We've
got minus one in the conduction band.
We've got plus one in the valence
band. And so,
under this same influence of
electric field,
the hole will move from left to
right. So, one promotion thermally
generates two carriers.
We get an electron in the conduction
band, and a hole in the valence band.
So, now we have some conductivity
that is quite different from what
we're used to.
And in fact, the numbers are equal,
right? The number of electrons that
we generate is equal to the number
of holes that we generate.
Electrical engineers will represent
this in a more compact notation.
They don't want to know the
chemistry. Electrical engineers
historically were afraid of
chemistry. They just classify these
things on the basis of their
functionality.
Electrons are negative carriers.
Holes are positive carriers, so in
electrical engineering parlance,
you'll see this equation, n equals p,
meaning the number of negative
carriers is equal to the number of
positive carriers.
So, this comes out of thermal
excitation. And,
so now, we could say something
intelligent about conductivity.
We can say that electrical
conductivity must be related to this.
So, I know I was using sigma over
there for bonds.
We are running out of characters.
We've burned the Latin alphabet.
We've burned through the Greek
alphabet. But here we are.
So, sigma now represents electrical
conductivity of the specimen.
And, we know the electrical
conductivity of the specimen must be
related to the number of carriers.
Population of carriers,
all right, and it must be related to
the charge on the carriers.
In other words, if I had plus one,
all other things being equal, plus
two, all other things being equal,
the plus twos will get me double the
conductivity of the plus ones.
So, charge or, let's say, charge on
unit carrier, and then lastly there
is a term called mobility
of the carrier.
What's the mobility?
The mobility is the ease with which
the carrier can move through the
crystal. You can define mobility as
the velocity per unit electric field.
So, if I have two carriers,
one is in copper. It moves very
quickly. One is in silicon,
moves very slowly. I apply the same
voltage across equally
sized specimens.
I find one moves more quickly than
the other. The concept that
captures that is called mobility.
So, if I take the product of the
population, the charge,
and the mobility, I end up with
something that gives me conductivity.
And, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to sum this over all of my
carriers because each carrier
contributes. A negative current
going from right to left will
contribute to a positive current
going from left to right.
OK, so we can now write this.
We can write in the case of this
crystal here, we only have two
carriers. We've got electrons,
and we've got holes. So, we can say
it's the number of electrons times
the charge on the electron -
absolute value - is the unit charge
times the mobility of the electron
plus the number of holes times the
charge on a hole,
which is the unit charge,
and the mobility of the hole.
So, we also know that the number of
electrons equals the number of holes
in thermal excitation.
So then, that allows us to write,
this is n sub E. It's the same,
times the elementary charge times
the sum of the mobilities.
And, those mobilities in many
instances in this crystal
are roughly the same.
So, we can get a measure of what the
conductivity is from this.
Now, I'm going to show you an
equation that we're not going to
derive from first principles,
but from the more elaborate form of
quantum mechanics,
allows us to estimate the number of
electrons that have been thermally
excited in a crystal,
and it looks like this.
It's got a pre-factor times
absolute temperature to the three
halves, and an equation that has a
ratio of the binding energy and the
disruptive energy.
And that's done through an
exponential where we put the band
gap energy in the numerator,
and some measure of thermal energy
in the denominator.
And, the way we characterize
thermal energy is the product of the
Boltzmann constant,
and absolute temperature.
So, this is a measure of the
binding energy,
all right, and this is a measure of
the disruptive energy.
And, we've seen that notion before
and we're going to see it again
where we make an exponential.
There's going to be a minus here.
And, because we get two carriers
for excitation,
there will be a two here.
And now we are ready to elaborate.
This kB, just to be clear, is the
Boltzmann constant.
And, the Boltzmann constant is 1.
8 times ten to the minus 23 joules
per Kelvin.
It's the amount of energy per degree
rise times temperature will give us
an energy term.
We know the band gap energy,
and so by evaluating this, it turns
out for silicon at room temperature,
the value is ne for silicon at room
temperature is equal to 1.
times ten to the tenth carriers per
centimeter cubed.
1.3 times ten to the tenth,
you say, well, that's 10 billion.
Well, how many carriers are there
in copper per cubic centimeter?
In copper, per cubic centimeter,
we did the calculation. For copper,
we have one carrier per copper
atom.
And we said for copper,
we've got roughly Avogadro's number
of copper atoms per cubic centimeter.
So, in copper,
that analogous quantity is going to
be on the order of ten to the 23rd
per centimeter cubed.
So, what's the difference?
The difference is that silicon,
native silicon, pure undoped silicon
has a value of carrier
concentration.
Ne of copper to ne of silicon at
room temperature is at the order of
about 10 trillion.
And so, you can see the power of
band theory because it's now
allowing you to make sense of the
various values in conductivity.
I showed you last day, copper is up
at 5.9 times ten to the seventh
Siemens per meter.
So, if we take now the conductivity
of pure silicon in the same units,
we're down here at ten to the minus
four.
And if you take the ratio of ten to
the plus seven over ten to the minus
four, it's about ten to the 11th.
And, this is giving us ten to the
13th. And, all I've done is look at
this first term,
population of carriers.
We're talking about the same
carrier, same charge.
Clearly there's something here
that's in the mobility.
Where do you think you're going to
have much higher mobility of
electrons, in a metallically bonded
structure, or in a covalently bonded
structure? I think you can see that
the mobility of electrons in silicon
is going to be much lower.
Whether it's 100 times or not is
something to be seen,
but I think you can see that the
band theory is helping us make sense
of what's going on.
So, I think this is probably a good
place to stop.
I just want to give you one thing
to ponder over the Columbus Day
weekend. I told you that the
measure of thermal energy is the
product of the Boltzmann constant
times temperature.
And, if you take room temperature
and you multiply it times the
Boltzmann constant,
this value at room temperature is
about one 40th of an electron volt.
Yet the band gap energy is 1.1,
which is much,
much higher than the thermal energy,
how is it that we get any thermal
excitation? That's what I'm going
to answer next day.
Before you go, I wanted to go back
to Siemens and show one
of his many inventions.
I've shown you silicon,
high purity silicon. Where do we
get silicon from?
This is the silicon age.
We live in the silicon age.
So, silicon starts on the beach.
You start with sand, Quartzite.
And, we take silica,
and we feed it into this furnace,
which was invented by Siemens. It's
an electric arc furnace.
It has three carbon electrodes,
and these are fed by AC power. And,
we put the sand in here with a few
other ingredients,
and the action of electric current
passing between the electrodes
actually melts the charge.
So, you have this liquid honey-like
goo of silica and some other
ingredients, and then the reaction
proceeds. The carbon reduces the
silica to elemental silicon and
generates carbon monoxide.
And, the carbon comes from the
electrodes themselves so,
you consume the electrode.
See, the electrodes are constantly
being fed like giant drafting
pencils into the charge while they
are passing current.
And now we make silicon.
And the silicon is full of
impurities because sand has iron in
it. It's got aluminum in it.
It's got Lord knows what else in it.
And that's not going to make high
purity silicon for microelectronic
devices. So, you might say,
how are we going to make high purity
silicon? We're talking about 99.
99999 times. People talk about six
nines, seven nines purity.
One part per million, one part per
billion, how are you going to get
from this glop here that's full of
iron, aluminum,
and also saturated with carbon?
What are you going to do? Somebody
might say, why don't we
distill the silicon?
Well, silicon melts at 1,
18 degrees centigrade. It boils at
a temperature above 2,
00 C at atmospheric pressure.
What are you going to contain this
stuff in? How are you going to
ensure purity?
And, how much energy are you going
to consume? That won't work.
So, what happens instead is people
get smart and use some chemistry.
So, they take this impure silicon
and chlorinate it with HCl.
See, we've met silicon,
it's sp3 hybridized. We've met HCl
and it's polar.
And, it forms this molecule,
trichlorosilane. And guess what?
The inter-atomic, right, secondary
bonding is weak in this material.
And it boils at 33¡ C. That's
below body temperature.
You hold this in your hand,
and the stuff will start boiling.
So, what can you do? Well, what
happens to the iron?
What happens to the aluminum?
What happens to all the other crud?
It doesn't form this.
So, now, you can selectively
transfer with minimal energy.
The trichlorosilane, fractionally
distill it to get very,
very high purity, trichlorosilane.
Then you go back and you convert to
silicon. And,
how do you do that?
You pass it over a hot wire at high
temperature, this is unstable.
So, see, we are playing with
chemistry. We are playing with
temperature. These are the tricks.
This is the playbook.
So, now, we've got a high
temperature. We've got a hot wire.
How do we make a wire hot? With a
flame? No. We pass electric
current through it.
And, the molecules of
trichlorosilane hit the hot wire in
the presence of hydrogen,
back react to form HCl, silicon
tetrachloride,
and silicon. And,
it's this silicon that comes out of
that first operation that then goes
for subsequent zone melting to make
the giant single crystal from which
we cut this piece right here.
And, all this goes back to the 1800s.
By about 1870,
Siemens was running furnaces like
this. There is one other important
application for this furnace that's
used to this day.
It's recycling steel.
Steel is the number one recycled
metal by far, not the aluminum
beverage can, steel.
In this country, there's about 12
million tons of steel consumed for
automobile industry,
and about 12 million tons of steel
go back into recirculation.
And, this is the furnace.
You take scrap metal,
electric arc furnace, slag on top,
remelt, purify, and then it goes
back into the marketplace.
OK, have a nice weekend.